[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm christopher hine and
this week we're talking about live
training drills in aikido
this today we're going to talk about the
box drill what we call the box drill
which is again one of my favorite drills
i really enjoy this drill i think it's
great
the idea of this drill is you put
someone in a box and you have other
people
circle around the outside of the box and
come in at random times
and this is training the the nage the
person in the middle of the box
to be calm and pay attention to people
around them at all different angles i'm
going to call josh and maya out here see
if we can go to work for you guys
okay so we're going to put maya in the
middle of the box put her in the hot
seat today
all right i'm all mic'ed up so i'm going
to try to be as mellowly active as i can
but still we need one more person at
least for this drill this drill really
works great if you have
uh three or four or five people that's
really good we've even run it with up to
eight people before so
more numbers just makes it harder and
harder so basically the idea this is
josh and i are going to circle the
outside of the box
so we're always moving around what maya
is trying to learn to do is keep track
of both of us now we can switch
directions
go anywhere any way we want we can try
to work to stay behind her one of us can
always work to do that we can try and
distract
her right so we can do anything we want
to mess with her sensitivity to what's
going on
now once we enter the box we are going
to run
in a straight line through the box so if
i enter the box i'm not going to hang
out here
like this right um and the reason is
because we're really trying to train
immediate awase for maya
from an attack from any direction so
that's the focus of this drill
is to work on that so when i come in i'm
going to run in a straight line through
it at maya now if maya moves to the side
i'll track her so if she came this way
i'll track her over here if she moves
that way i'll track her over there
but i'm not going to stop in the box
meaning once my foot's in the box i'm
going at maya if she goes
right or left i'll track her right or
left but uh i'm going right at maya
okay so josh and i are going to go
around the box like this whenever we
want
we're going to try to go through and
knock maya out of the box that's our
objective
maya wants to make good blends with that
so i'm trying to look for moments
when she's not paying attention so we're
both working on that we're trying to
mess with her as much as we can
so she becomes uncomfortable so you see
how she's dancing around right now she's
like what are they trying to pull on me
and that's what we really want right so
we're looking for those moments okay
now we can also work together there's no
reason why we can't work together
what we're not going to do though is
step in the box and go like this
because it's a tiny box right so if we
were in a room that small you probably
wouldn't get to do ikea what we're
trying to do is teach her on the spot
how to do good clean awase right so we
circle around the box
if we want to come in we come in we're
trying to drive her actively out of the
box so it's just a shove it's all we're
looking for
that's the idea so this is the box drill
it's a drill i really like to run
especially for new people because it
starts teaching them how to make a wasa
if they're coming from the back or from
the left or from the right
how to quickly make a decision and move
and blend this is the
box drill i'm christopher hines aikido
fresno thanks for watching
[Music]